well I think there's a mindset from the
Chernobyl accident that you know nuclear
power is Verbolten quite frankly eighty
percent of the power and France comes
from the nuclear industry surely we can
be as bold as the French there's a waste
disposal problem the French have a
reprocessing system secretary Chu who I
admired greatly in this administration
believes that in the next 10 or 15 years
new technology will develop better than
reprocessing so what I'm willing to do
work with administration to provide a
jumpstart of building nuclear power
plants loan guarantees that will back
these plants up reform the regulatory
process like they do in France so that
we can really get on with developing
nuclear power I understand environmental
concerns but every technology has some
downside I think nuclear power has
proven over time to be a safe reliable
form of power in the good news it
doesn't emit co2 the other good news is
it creates a lot of high-tech jobs that
we need and a lot of environmentalists
are changing their position the
environmental community I tried to work
on a comprehensive energy bill with
Senator Lieberman and carry what was
pretty practical quite frankly